bombshells United launches DC's top
super heroines on an all-new adventure
and it starts with Wonder Woman
confronting the internment of
japanese-americans in 1943 writer
Marguerite Bennett is dropping in to
tell us all about the explosive series
so Marguerite why did you decide to
Center this story around Japanese
internment camps I was with my family
and flipping through one of my cousin's
textbooks and I saw that his section on
World War 2 and the American involvement
World War two had zero mention of
Japanese internment and you know I grew
up with leak you know I'd learned about
that in middle school and so it seems
strange because that he's a little bit
older than that and so I looked at my
older cousins textbook and it was also
missing there and so you know maybe
there was an element that it was you
know like East Coast versus West Coast
but it was just the fact that you know
when I was child you know World War two
seems so far away everything in the past
seems you know so radically distant and
as I get older the past seems closer and
closer to me and as this generation you
know is getting older and as we're
beginning to lose them so we're
beginning to lose you know their their
eyewitness accounts and their stories it
seemed even more important to use a
platform that I had that was involving
this era in order to highlight moments
within our own history that we failed as
a nation you know that we failed as a
culture and to learn from those lessons
and to understand that you have the
opportunity and the responsibility every
day to change the narrative of your
family of yourself and of your nation it
seems irresponsible for me to have this
opportunity and to let it pass by and
use that you know as the opportunity to
show heroism in so many different forms
that it's not you know I know it seems
cliché to say okay it's not about
superpowers but it's about understanding
that you have a responsibility to your
history so I mean less I want to know
about is tell us a little about Donna
and Cassie's relationship with Wonder
Woman in the substratum series we
focused primarily on the story of these
japanese-american girls who are you know
being sent to these internment camps and
so they're the ones who come up with
this heist break out plan and so they
wind up getting in touch with Wonder
Woman and so she is
quite literally instrumental in that you
know she comes in she helps them execute
the plan but the plan is is their design
and their decision they have the agency
and they work together you know like
with wonder when I'm with her training
um you know to escape you know this is a
huge train highest but it becomes you
know the largest story is okay you know
you did the Prison Break what do you do
now what what comes next and so it's you
know it's a it's a complicated and
emotional story and you know we get to
see some incredible villains including
Clayface I don't know if I can say that
it's um you know we're gonna there's so
many villains that I've you know from
playing a bit close the Testaments were
saving for a very special art so a new
digital issue comes out this Friday can
you give us a tease or a hint about what
readers could expect in the issue
absolutely
um so back in 2014 when Jim Chadwick my
wonderful editor on the first bombshell
series first approached me I master this
breakdown I think he was expecting like
three pages and I sent in 18 one of them
included this scene that you know that
it's coming up you know and in the new
issue and you know it was one of the
boombastic messed up sequence and it was
the kind of thing that when I was
picking people the series like I would
after the whole thing out you know so
I'm very very excited you know four
years later to find we get to bring that
to fruition that's what you can expect
in bombshells unite it and here's a full
rundown of the DC titles hitting shelves
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
that's the news for now but if you're
behind on some of your favorite DC
titles then catch up with the new
collected editions for all-star Batman
and Suicide Squad
see you tomorrow Superfriends